werden jetzt schon 37 sekunden können
sie das auch selber behalten
seit 100 jahren schon und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich geht es heute
startet das video mal wieder aus dem
auto wir haben also kein warmes wetter
in deutschland
ich glaube heute sind sie schon 30 grad
und nächste woche soll es 40 grad werden
habe ich zumindest als gelesen in köln
wird es nächste woche in die mittwochs
glaube ich 40 grad auf jeden fall setzt
sich deswegen auch heute in diesem auto
das ist ein bisschen größer das gehört
meine eltern weil in meinem muss dann
die klimaanlage kaputt ist er die wird
irgendwann in den nächsten tagen
repariert aber das würde ich mir nicht
wirklich antun dass es so schlimm da
drin vor allem das auto auf schwarzer
aber ich erzähle schon wieder viel zu
viel
heute machen wir einen zweiten part von
die habe ich das letzte mal genannt ich
sag mal so fast food mitarbeitern
geldspenden wenn letztes mal was solche
hundert euro abgehoben und habe dann
immer dem fastfood mitarbeiter der halt
am schalter steht geld gegeben wenn die
eismaschine funktioniert hat weil ihr
kennt ja wahrscheinlich selber ab und zu
ist die mal kaputt das war beim letzten
mal ein bisschen fehl weil die hat bei
jedem funktioniert so das hätte ich
jetzt gar nicht mal unbedingt gedacht
deswegen haben wir heute neue trends ich
muss jetzt erstmal hier schnell noch
geld wohl es geht heute darum ich gebe
die bestellung auf ich höre jetzt noch
ein paar freunde ab weil wir sind heute
ein paar mehr dann wird es ganz lustiger
und wenn ich die bestellung nachdem ich
sie aufgegeben habe unter einer minute
an der hand halte also die gesamte
bestellung daten kriegen die geld von
mir wieder irgendwie weiß nicht was hat
mal gesagt hat es mal auf jeden fall
gibt es ein ganz dickes trinkgeld und
ich bin auf die reaktionen gespannt
falls das irgendwie überhaupt schafft
und eine minute also das den challenge
für das heutige video
ich gehe jetzt schon einmal geld holen
weil ich habe gerade nichts und ist
gleich alter das ist immer das
allerbeste auf dem dorf in der umgebung
von 5 kilometer ist ein und scheiß
autobahn und der geht nicht machen was
mache ich denn jetzt na ja das wetter
ist schön war ich bin ein bisschen krank
auch wir lassen uns das gar nicht die
laune verderben ich war halt jetzt zum
nächsten was bleibt mir anderes übrig so
leute also ich weiß bei der bank wir
haben hier wieder 100 euro das hat
diesmal nicht so ganz geklappt wie ich
es mir vorgestellt habe ich wollte
wieder 520 haben
eigentlich besser jetzt haben wir halt
auch den 50er und ich habe es auch zwei
freunde dabei die mich heute begleiten
werden also dann wird es nicht ganz so
langweilig damit noch mal kurz die idee
klar ist also fahren dadurch wir
bestellen ein eis ein cheeseburger und
ein kleines getränk und die haben ab der
bestellung nachdem ich das letzte wort
sage so als zum beispiel dann das letzte
wort ist oder der letzte teil der
bestellung ist halt eine kleine cola
dann gilt eine minute und wenn dir das
innerhalb dieser minute uns geben können
kriegen die alt ist fährt trinkl so und
dann checken wir einfach die reaktion
von den absagen und wir fahren direkt
mal los weil erstens mcdonald's dann zu
bürgerkriegen und dann gucken wir mal
war noch lang so ist aber ich passe dann
sieht man da sieht man die kosten
nein das wird schon länger oder leute
also wir sind jetzt da das ding ist ein
auto ist auch vor uns also louis du
shops die zeit ne du kannst dann immer
zwischendurch so an die kamera halten ja
wieviel autos sind vor uns 22 okay
die haben eine minute würde ich sagen
oder wollte und erst wenn das letzte
ich hätte gerne einen cheeseburger ja
dann ein mc sunday mit schoko und eine
kleine kohle
das wäre es schon danke
also jetzt eine minute wende schaffen
ich hoffe nicht
kennedy schaffen
hilft es schon um die hälfte ist schon
um 15 sekunden 15 sekunden
wir sind so wirklich also nicht wahr die
leute die schon seit zwei minuten da
stehen haben wir es also das war absolut
ich würde sagen vielleicht ist eine
minute dann auch ein bisschen zu knapp
dann sagen wir beim nächsten mal 130
aber in einer minute dreißig da ist
wirklich macht meiner meinung nach also
ich hatte schon recht viele bestellungen
die zeit in einer auf die kette kriegt
haben wenn nicht sogar noch schneller du
isst kennt ja auch der eine oder andere
von euch hin
das ist ja der wie läuft eigentlich mit
einer öffnung für den richtig gut
also das essen war wohl am besten am
besten schmeckt oder das ist die eine
heute aus aber echt ewig leute wir sind
jetzt schon bei über 3 minuten also
eigentlich haben können wir hier schon
aufhören oder wir sehen uns dann gleich
beim nächsten
[Musik]
danke also leute das hat jetzt über fünf
minuten gedauert ich glaube das war
jetzt wirklich also keine ahnung obwohl
da eigentlich viele gearbeitet haben
irgendwas nicht gerade nicht so gut okay
bei mcdonald's war es schon mal nix die
haben immer fünf minuten gebraucht ist
es eine fliege im auto wir fahren jetzt
als nächstes zu burger king und da hätte
ich eigentlich gedacht und hier die
schaffen es auf keinen fall unter einer
minute deswegen geben wir den jetzt
schon mal eineinhalb minuten also dies
war eineinhalb minuten 22 gerne ein
kleines cola getränk dazu einen
cheeseburger und ein kleines eis wird
karamell das war alles klar
okay leute die zeit läuft über die 20
hallo
der rest ist für dich
von dem geld gemacht gerade so eine
kleine challenge und ihr wart mich dass
die schnellsten ehrlicher aber du musst
vor allem weil du hast oder eine halbe
minute als ein so als trinkgeld ehrlich
aber jetzt ganz schnell waren sonst ist
es die zu ihrer zeit abgelaufen
jetzt wird's noch mal die wir jetzt
nicht so begeistert davon
die kommission ist es geschafft das sind
10 euro
es war noch viel mehr als zehn ja also
ich muss sagen von allen leuten denen
ich bis jetzt dann geld geschenkt habt
war dass auf jeden fall die
unspektakulär erste reaktion gesagt also
man hat ja gesehen dass sie sich also
man hat hier angesehen dass ich also man
hat sie angesehen dass sie sich gefreut
hat aber ja wir fahren jetzt weiter weil
ich will auf jeden fall noch mehr freude
und dafür fahren wir uns extra über die
autobahn weil wir haben hier schon in
mecklenburg hinter uns und mehr gibt's
nämlich leute wir sind ja schon beim
nächsten teil
das problem ist dass es extrem voll und
das ist ja dann unfair weil wenn die
leute vor uns halt so lange brauchen
dann können ja die mitarbeiter für mich
deswegen warten wir jetzt ein bisschen
dass es ein bisschen länger wird und
dann haben die auf eineinhalb minuten zu
schaffen kriegen sowie dann für das
trinkgeld und ich hoffe diesmal wird
sich mehr gefreut als davor dass x oder
nico ich hoffe dass lehrer geworden
zumindest ein bisschen wir versuchen
jetzt einfach mal vielleicht glaubt ja
wenn nicht dann halt ich kann man ja
nicht wissen hallo ich hätte gerne einen
cheeseburger ein kleines cola und ein
großer vanilleeis mit auch ein
vanilleeis mit schokolade
[Musik]
und ihr habt verloren die
hier wollte ich habe jetzt gerade zeit
und eigentlich kann man schon wieder
sagen dass wir wieder negativ in der
kasse allein schon die zeit gekommen um
mir das wechselgeld zu geben also
natürlich die können das ja auch nicht
wissen dass ich den geld schenken möchte
aber ich hab's noch nicht verdient wer
will kann es eigentlich daraus bauen
leute wir sehen uns gleich beim nächsten
ein machen wir auf jeden fall noch okay
wir sind jetzt beim letzten dass jetzt
wieder ein deutscher film hier und das
ist eigentlich auch schon der letzte auf
unserer route weil sonst müssen wir
extrem weit fahren um noch irgendein zu
finden und wer das jetzt hier wieder
nichts wird ich finde das sieht aber gut
aus weil da ist überhaupt kein autorin
oder nicholas kein automat also ist
komplett frei das heißt auch die haben
jetzt wieder eineinhalb minuten und
eigentlich ist das her locker machbar
deswegen hoffe ich dass jetzt klappt
wenn nicht dann habe ich heute halt
nicht viel geld ausgegeben hallo ich
hätte gerne ein vlies bürger ein kleines
eis mit schokolade und ein
eine kleine krone das wäre es schon
okay leute los geht's also eigentlich
können sie das jetzt locker schaffen für
uns ist jetzt irgendwie ein auto das
war's und was wir dort auch aufgefallen
ist dass 44 euro
was meint ihr wird das was ich glaube
die haben was schweres bestellt was
schweres wird irgendwo aufs nordmeer
wieder eng werden jetzt schon 37
sekunden
und was wenn das kann was werden wir
haben noch
[Musik]
der rest ist für sie weil sie so schnell
sind ganze ist franziska 37 naja ich
finde hier ist für dich und für meine
kollegin weil ihr sohn der frau so
schnell sein die war ein richtig schönes
oft positionen können wir das auch
selber behalten als trinke gern haben
sich schon mal so viel trinken seit
eineinhalb jahren schon noch nie einen
so schönen tag
die haben sich doch richtig gefreut dass
heute kann das jetzt unter sich zu
aufgeteilt und verläuft in den
kommentaren unter dem letzten fahrt
gelesen dass sie das nicht behalten
dürfen und ich habe ihn jetzt gerade
gefragt und habt ihr gehört darf das als
trinkgeld bei jungen branche im
hintergrund okay also eigentlich weiß
dass mit dem video
wenn ihr sagt mache auf jeden fall noch
ein paar scheinbar die idee was wir
machen sollen in die kommentare
ihr seid auch wieder herzlich eingeladen
mitzukommen und ein bisschen es umsonst
finden ja ich hab natürlich es hat euch
gefallen
jack verzückung ab und auch das von nico
ciao